you get to charge whatever you want you
make a lot more money we need to see
your powerful opinion come out in every
single piece of content people will
notice you will start to get speaking
gigs
what's that believe nation it's heaven
my one word is believe and I believe in
you I believe you have Michael Jordan
level talent at something and I want you
to find it embrace it and make a
difference using it so to help you on
your journey today I'm gonna talk about
the seven ways that you can make money
from book deals and speaking engagements
enjoy so this video is brought to you by
the workshop that I'm putting on in May
in Toronto I'm picking 15 people to help
them be a thought leader be an expert
and turn what you've got in here to go
out have a big impact and make money
doing it building your empire off of
your thoughts we have three spots left
where 80% sold out if anybody wants to
join check the link in the description
today I'm going to talk about the seven
different ways that you can make money
from book deals and speaking gigs it's
off one of the things that get asked a
lot about I'm an expert I have ideas I
want to be a speaker I want to be an
author how do I make some money doing it
some covering it at my workshop in
Toronto but I'm gonna give you a sneak
peek here with a high-level overview of
my seven tips so here's how this video
breaks down we number one is gonna apply
to both book deals and speaking gigs way
two three four is gonna be only about
books and wave five six seven are gonna
be only both speaking engagement because
they're slightly different beasts
[Music]
so way number one is gonna be have an
audience this sounds like a no-brainer
but you have to have an audience the
more you have an audience the more
people gonna care about you the more
comfort is gonna want to hire you to
speak and the more covers gonna work
with you to publish a book one of the
first things is gonna happen if you want
to publish a book whether use a
publisher or self publish and we'll get
into the details later in this video is
what's your audience
what's your reach and they want to see
that you have reached not just on
YouTube or Instagram or Facebook or
Twitter but also direct access like
email addresses you will definitely get
asked how many email addresses do you
have because they want to see that you
can help promote the thing if you can
help promote the book if you can help
promote the speaking event you're gonna
get paid a lot more than if you can't if
you are counting on them to do
everything it's gonna be a lot harder to
get the big-ticket deals and so listen
this is a long-term game you may not
have much of an audience right now
that's okay but this is where the world
is going in this industry and so the
sooner you get out to start building in
your community you start building a
tie-in to fan base on the different
social platforms and collecting email
addresses the more it's gonna set you up
for success success success success over
and over and over again so start
building your audience now ok let's
start talking about the books way number
two is to use a publisher the reason to
use a publisher is one to get a little
bit more credibility if you're just
getting started people may not know you
there's still a little bit of a cachet
around having a book with a major
publisher my first book was with penguin
Random House so I can say I'm a penguin
Random House author I think the
credibility is slowly declining it
doesn't mean as much as it used to
there's a lot more ways to get notoriety
publicity awareness attention than just
having a book before a book used to be
the opening door to a lot of
opportunities now having my youtube
channel is an example is what I'm gonna
lead with much more than I have a book
with penguin Random House and so there's
other ways to do it but it still gives
you more credibility you're not gonna
make as much money with the publisher
they likely will not give you an advance
unless you have a big audience so I got
an advance from my publisher but most
people would not as a
I'm author until you've proven yourself
and so your first book expect not to
make a lot from the advance and not to
make much from the royalties either
you're basically taking a shot that this
is going to work out and if it does sell
then your future books you'll be able to
get advances on and it keeps increases
that you're doing more sales but that
first one is a proof of concept and so
you're not gonna make a lot of money but
you will get in bookstores you will get
attention recognition for having a major
publisher behind you so you need to
weigh the options what's more important
to you making money or getting the book
with the brand name in the bookstores
[Music]
wait number three is to get a literary
agent so a literary agent their job is
to find new authors and connect them to
publishers and so I got introduced to my
Lit agent through my regular agent and
she did a great job what she did was
she'll look at the proposal so when
you're creating a proposal for a a major
publishing company they want to see a
couple things they want to see they want
to know you they want to know your
mission they want to know what you
staying for they want to know why you're
doing the thing that you're doing they
want to know what your reach is how big
your audience is they also want to see
the outline for the book what's the big
idea from this book it should be easy to
understand what the big idea from this
book is and they also want to see the
the chapter outline so how many chapters
are in the book how many pages is gonna
be roughly give or take and you know
what are the main points in each chapter
and then they also want to see a sample
chapter so not just the outline they
want to see the first chapter done they
want to get a sense to your writing
style they want to get a sense of is it
powerful is it meaningful is it
something that they want to be able to
go off and sell and so there's a lot of
work and create a proposal for a
publisher so that's where a lit agent
they take a commission take a cut of
what you end up selling your book for or
you know commissions coming in to take a
piece but they're great because they can
help you one navigate the waters of
dealing with publishers and creating a
proposal that's really gonna win because
you might only get one shot with a
publisher so she has a new author and if
your proposal sucks they likely won't
want to look at it again unless you've
done something dramatic on your audience
to really build up notoriety around
yourself the second thing they do though
is he create a bidding war so I'm not
able to mention pricing but what my lit
agent basically did was put what five
different publishers against each other
and we had five calls in two days
and back-to-back-to-back and she creates
a bidding war where I ended up making a
lot more than the first offer from the
publisher because we pitted one
publisher against each other so just
like a good real estate agent I guess
would do try to create a bidding war
between different buyers if you're
trying to sell a house and so getting on
board with the lit agent could really
help you the way in you can you can
google you can find them you can reach
out most of these people are
individually on Twitter as well as you
know professionally the brain being on
Twitter you can find them at trade shows
events you can look for referrals
introductions you can find them on
LinkedIn there's a lot of paths in and
the more of that work that you've done
up front
the more you thought about the proposal
remember the key sections that I talked
about what are you doing what's the why
what's the mission what's the book about
what's what's the chapter overviews what
is your reach all of that stuff the more
you've already thought that through and
the less they have to help you the more
likely you're gonna get a yes if they
see opportunities in what you're
creating
[Music]
wait number four is to self-published so
I self-published my second book the top
ten rose to success I wanted to try both
so first one your one word paying a
random house second one I use create
space in Amazon to sell publish you get
to charge whatever you want you make a
lot more money especially off the
digital downloads then you do when you
go with a publisher it's a lot harder to
get into the bookstores it probably
won't happen so it depends on what
you're trying to do you are
self-publishing just with Amazon's you
don't have a brand name behind you you
won't be in the book store so if your
goal is to walk into a store and and see
your thing there it's a possibility but
it's really really really hard to get in
but you'll be able to make a lot more
money and it's a hundred percent on you
to be able to sell now publishers do a
little bit of work to help you they try
to line up a little bit of media and
some of their contacts but don't expect
the publishers to do a lot these days
it's really up to the author
anyway to sell which is why they really
care about your audience so it just
comes down to how much are you trying to
get money versus how much you're trying
to get exposure and if money is your
primary goal and you want speed and you
want total control editorial control
everything control cover everything then
sub publishing is the way to go let's
move on to speaking now let's get some
speaking gigs way number five you need
to have a powerful opinion this is the
start if you want to get hired to be a
speaker then you need to stand for
something what is your message you can't
just be a photocopy of somebody else
what are you staying for you need to
speak with authority on that topic you
need to be a subject matter expert and
you have to have an opinion that is
different and so the more that you could
tie it to a specific niche and the more
that you can tie it to current events
and what's happening in the world today
and give your two cents on it and spin
it in a way that makes sense for an
audience a certain demographic not
everybody I get hired to come and speak
to people who want to be entrepreneurs
I'm not gonna go off and speak to people
who want to be truck drivers right so I
know my niche I know what I'm good at
and that's what you need to define for
yourself so who is your audience and
what is the powerful opinion that you
have that is different from everybody
else what is the perspective and then
start sharing that content we need to
see your powerful opinion come out and
every single piece of content that you
are making across all of your platforms
[Music]
way number six is film talking head
videos talking head is basically like
this I'm a talking head is not a ton of
fancy editing everything that we're
talking about is coming from here you
guys are not tuning in because of the
effects that we have or the splashy
music we've got going on that all helps
but really you're coming here to
understand what's in my head and
hopefully have a knowledge transfer that
helps you get to where you want to go
and so making talking head videos if you
want to be a speaker is one of the best
ways to become a speaker I get all of my
speaking gig opportunities from my
YouTube channel they see me talking they
like my powerful opinion they want me to
come and keynote an event that is going
on and more and more and more and more
that's where people are getting their
gigs from creating speaking videos on
YouTube there's an expression in the
speaking world that
if you want to speak more you need to
speak more that the more you speak the
more people see you even if you're
speaking for free doesn't mean you have
to the YouTube videos you could be going
out in the world and speaking for free
you know YouTube just gives you a much
greater audience a bigger platform and
people like it they see you they come
back they subscribe they watch more
videos they tell their friends they
share your content it gets picked up
somewhere a friend of a friend of a
friend and that person hires you to come
and speak and so the more practice you
get speaking one it makes you better
period so if you how many videos have I
made on my channel five six thousand
videos you get better at something after
you practice at five six thousand times
so you will just naturally get better
the quantity leads to the quality and
you increase your chances that somebody
is going to see your thing and pick it
up and want to tell their friend and
eventually hire you to come and speak at
their event so I'll be looking at how do
I make talking head videos this is this
this is not that hard to make because
they're not coming to you for your
over-the-top editing they're not coming
to you for your animation skills it
doesn't have to take a hundred hours to
make you know a three-minute film it's
you talking from the top of your head
you can get your phone out mine is not
here I'm using a webcam here right now I
have a channel 1.2 1.3 million
subscribers that I'm still using a
webcam for a lot of my videos my my
editor is not super happy always about
that but we fixed the zoom the auto
focus issue so that's fantastic get your
phone out start filming yourself just
stabilize it right put it on a shelf or
get a tripod and just start making
videos if you have a powerful opinion
and you know what you're talking about
you can add value if you could transfer
that knowledge and change the feeling of
emotion that you're feeling to the
people who are watching that video
that's when you start to win and that's
when people want to hire you to comment
if that's your industry I would say a
video a day a video every single day you
talking about something I'd be looking
at you know 7 - 8 - 9 - 10 minutes in
that range so something's happening in
the news or something is upsetting you
or you know you met a client and you're
telling a story
start with your powerful opinion then
start breaking down what the advice
should be give a story right
tell the story tell me the lesson from
her and then tell me what I should be
doing right that's that's a video every
day of the week right at least five
times a week weekdays at least get that
going out you should be able to come up
with those things if you want to be a
speaker you have to learn to be able to
speak you have to learn people that
access stories and bring them in and so
if you're not able to do that you need
the practice
you need to practice to get better and
so don't worry about the editing just go
and be able to make seven eight nine ten
minute video five times a week that
should be your media priority and way
number seven is to film speaking videos
so every time you get a speaking gig you
want to make sure that it is filmed
ideally from the venue themselves it's a
hopefully bigger venue they have a film
crew they have somebody doing it that
you can then take that footage and sign
like if you get an agreement I would
always try to put that in because it's
usually not in the agreement that you
get a copy of the video so try to write
that into the agreement if possible it's
not always possible sometimes it's a
private event and they don't want to
share it but always ask for it just in
case if they are not filming it try to
find a way to film it bring your own
tripod bring your cell phone bring a
friend
have somebody film it try to not to have
super shaky invest in a microphone
there's a zoom microphone you can buy
it's like a hundred bucks where you can
you put the microphone on and it just
clips here it doesn't have to tie into
the phone it's worth doing what you want
to do is have more content on your
channel of you speaking not just a
talking head video like this but you
onstage the more people see you on stage
the more twigs in their head oh this
person is a speaker I wonder if they
should come and speak at my next event
or I know my friend is putting on that
event they should really look at this
video and so ideally every single time
that you actually get a speaking gig
whether it's paid or free you have some
video format of it that you can then
upload it to your YouTube channel if you
want to be a speaker you need to have a
YouTube channel it's great to have
Instagram and do one minute videos and
it's great to have Twitter and do four
to five second videos but you need to
have a youtube channel and you need to
be uploading long-form Khan
you need to be showing yourself speaking
and showing the talking head videos as
well you do that consistently over and
over and over again and you actually
have a powerful opinion you actually
have a message to share people will
notice you will start to get speaking
gigs so those are my seven ways on how
to make money from book deals and
speaking gigs I would love to know what
did you think which one was the most
interesting that you're gonna now try to
apply in your life your business leave
it down the comments below did I miss an
8 9 10 that you want to add to the list
let me know leave it down there and for
those of you coming to Toronto I can't
wait to see you three more spots check
out the link in the description come
sign up I want to work with you one on
one I want to help you take that what
that is in here and explode it onto the
world in a powerful way that helps make
you money thank you guys so much for
watching I believe in you I hope you
continue to believe in yourself and
whatever your one word is much love I'll
see you soon if you had to think of one
word that's most important to you that
sums you Apple that would be collect a
little beacon pay believe nation if you
want to know what the most important one
word is for Tony Robbins Gary Vaynerchuk
Oprah Winfrey will.i.am and Howard
Schultz I have a very special secret
video for you check the description for
details